this statue must come down to show the
world
that people that gave their lives
throughout history
in this city in this state fighting for
freedom
did not do so and big episode of
southern charm
what did it mean to you to share this
moment in time
on television as you're saying it my
heart's kind of like beating
quickly it means a lot i really liked
the way it turned out it did portray how
heartfelt it really was and how naive i
was
okay so history lesson there is a
calhoun statue in the middle
of marion square parch and it is of john
c
calhoun obviously an ancestor of
catharines he wasn't he like the
like vice president or yes so he was
vice president two times
but he is known as a person who
fought to keep slavery as his last dying
wish
that's why catherine has a big name it's
calvin because i'm sure there are
a lot of ignorant people out there that
just don't know because they don't know
and so i think it really did portray the
feelings that went into it that day
i mean it was true to form i mean cat we
were like where's catherine
you know your
great-great-great-great-great-grandfather
do you know who that is
no but if your great-great-grandfather
was on a statue in the middle i would
not
you would never my ancestor i would say
no yeah
i thought it was very interesting you
chose not to invite catherine
to the meeting on the statue but then i
it seemed in your con
in a confessional later on that maybe
you wish you had extended that invite
and you had
pushed a little bit to be there
catherine should definitely be here
today
to just show up and be like i am related
to john c calhoun
what he did is not okay and i'm sorry
that would have been such a testament to
like
we're moving forward i think originally
i was like it's her responsibility to
know how did she not know this guy
she knows the statue's coming down she
should find out when and she should vote
you know
in my mind and i think as the season
goes on i start
to soften because originally i was so
like gobsmacked by it i kind of wish
she had been there but i also wanted to
respect my friends
zanita and megan and i wasn't sure if
they were ready to be at the table
with her you now have the opportunity to
make history for your family in a
different way
100 why would you not take that
opportunity to be on the right side of
history
i wish i knew what that privilege felt
like to be able to turn my back on
something because it doesn't affect me
megan point blank asks danny if she can
be friends with catherine
moving forward after having this
awakening
what are we going to see in terms of how
you guys interact with catherine in the
wake
of this conversation around the statue
but those
dms that were deemed racist i think that
we are
all able to i'm definitely respectful
with catherine and i can be in a room
with her and i can be kind to her
in terms of like you know friendship
that's a little trickier
i don't know about her and daniel i'm
just like guys i don't know why but i
will at the very least be
her like lowest battery bar it comes
second nature to me and i
i don't know how else to explain it but
that like i i know
before that global pandemic and all the
race stuff
she had just found out thomas was having
a baby like in a month
so there were a lot of things that i was
kind of like dude how can a human being
like
keep taking this and that's why i was
like dude i'm going to give her space
and she will reach out to me
and prioritize what is important what
isn't and when i didn't hear from her
that's when i was like just bummed we
know you do come face to face with her
to
talk through some of this stuff and it
looks like it does not go well
i just wanted to have a very simple easy
conversation with her and tell her my
feelings were hurt because she reached
out to love it before me
like that that was it as soon as she got
there i could tell
like it she just wasn't gonna hear it is
there something in your eyes i have on
fake eyelashes what the
are you covering then i am yeah
thanks for wasting my time okay danny
that wasn't even going to be a
conversation about the dms and the
racism stuff
this woman was bashing my friend katie
so i started responding i don't even
remember what i said but i do know the
monkey emoji ended up coming up
and now i'm being apparently racist that
was just gonna be a
friendship check-in everybody else would
do that
what she did was so stupid that's all i
would have to tell her like what the
[ __ ] were you thinking
what were you thinking like you know
better than this like that's what i
would say
in terms of that do you feel like at the
end of the day knowing everything that
was
filmed and where the season ended that
she walked away
learning from all of this and taking it
away hugely
do you believe catherine to be racist um
no
i don't believe that catherine is sort
of outwardly racist do i think that
she can be super embedded and like white
privilege
yeah like do i think she's tone deaf to
things that don't affect her yeah
she can tend to be just in her own head
honestly and she when she does
just random things like this is what got
me this is what's so funny
i'm like okay you didn't defend me when
i was in arguments with madison last
year but
you've known katie like as a side friend
and you're gonna just get up on the
internet and defend
of the trump rally like those are the
things i'm talking about
i'm like what frame of mind were you in
you know you have to be responsible for
your actions and
there was such an opportunity for her to
kind of take this and
turn it around in her favor and i'm just
like apologize for the sins we're
past and even though it was her but it
was her family and it's something that i
think would have been really special for
her to acknowledge
especially with a lot of like the local
charlestonians what do you hope
the audience takes away from this
episode well i'm hoping what they don't
take away is that you know
we're mad at people for their ancestors
which is not the case
i'm hoping that the takeaway from this
and you know as the season continues
that people see that
it's okay to have these awkward
conversations let's do some reading
let's understand what it is that i don't
understand
which is what made me make that shitty
comment you know what i mean i
like i've said i don't think council
culture serves anybody but i think
that addressing it you know i was hard
on catherine but she needed that
she needed that for it to sort of
get her to wake up to it because she you
know with affluence or
privilege comes responsibility that's
that's the cross
you have to bear you know and and and it
can be tremendous
like imagine what you can do with that
that's what i
i want the takeaway to be because i just
at the end of the day i just want it to
be better for our kids
i wanted to be better for catherine's
kids it's time for us to move on
happy man really
you